Burton Cummings of course now everyone
remembers the who but this was the guess
who remember yeah there's always
confusion you were first right we were
confused many times no actually the who
were first they were yeah we were from
Canada they were from England and
actually Burton had so many hits that
with the publishing and you own all the
you publish he wrote those songs I wrote
pretty well everything either wrote or
co-wrote pretty well everything Wow
got a nice award for a song of my called
stand tall yeah I was over 1 million air
place which is a very elite list do a
little bit of stand tall for us right
now as we talk to you this will be just
8:30 once in my heck oh yeah all right
go ahead a little bit of stand tall
[Applause]
in this
never knew
never heartache
but then again
I never lost in love
[Music]
somewhere
[Music]
maybe all those years we'll find
just can't think about him now
nice nice y-you want to hit the high
notes at 7:00 in the morning when you
hit the high note can you hit it
probably can yes show up a little hit
the high note hit the high note
stains all dock you fall
Godse don't don't do something foolish
[Applause]
you're feeling right now you can that's
a beautiful song that's a million plays
you got only an air please and that
means every time they play it they got
to pay you something right oh yeah think
about when you wrote that song that one
was one of those love songs that came
from a truly bad experience with the
same girl for about eight or nine years
and she said maybe we should have a
little hiatus from each other and this
was when you were in famous so I was
still you were famous girl from back
home in Winnipeg we've been together
eight or nine years and she said maybe
we'll have a little hiatus from each
other I bet she's sorry well three
months later she married a lawyer so she
got what she deserved what was your
biggest hit I think American woman have
the biggest chart position - a little of
American woman do it but it's a guitar
song so why do so do a different kind of
rendition you come on let's have some
fun a little difference yeah yeah we
want to hear the Burton Cummings owned
[Music]
as
[Music]
[Music]
CEO phase
I'm dr. John yeah but I like that I like
now what was the American woman about it
was just jammed it was it wasn't really
as much an anti-american song as it was
a pro Canadian song we had been touring
on the strength of our first few records
these eyes laughing and undone
and we were touring the state so we're
still Canadian kids I was 20 21 all
these gold records and went back to
Canada and I noticed the basic
difference between the women in America
and Canada is I think they grow up
faster in this country right and it's
just a slower pace because there's less
people right now back to Canada and I
looked down into the audience that night
and I started thinking to myself well
Canadian woman I prefer you but what
came out of my mouth was American
woman's stay away from me then all of a
sudden they read all these these
inferences into the song like they
thought I was talking about the Statue
of Liberty and all these things plus
nations refused to play it because it
was American woman stay away from me
initially they did but but this was 1970
the Vietnam War was at a particularly
bad point of escalation and it just
caught on and then it just snowballed it
became a huge record so how old were you
when you wrote songs like laughing
laughing I was I think 21 21 years old
and what were you doing laughing he said
all right a song where did you become so
arrogant that you became such a great
songwriter you said now again I think
this was a sad love affair song no
actually that was way before any real
serious relationships happened Randy
Backman and I wrote that in a on a bus
one time on a ferry we were in our old
highway bus on a ferry going from
Vancouver to Vancouver Island and you
wrote that and how long but 20 minutes
let me hear a little of that do although
20 minutes they wrote
[Music]
but because your
has passed me by surprise
[Music]
I was worried
Tango's so
[Music]
laughing come on to me
does it laugh
see I could sing that I like when you
sing along yeah I need to we'll get into
involved Burton you're doing great do
Underwood you do a little
all right here's Burton Cummings undone
she's come on
and when I found what she was headed for
too late she's come under
she found a mountain that was far too
high
she couldn't
[Music]
she's got to fun she's lost a son
[Music]
she
he's come
[Music]
that's great I know what that's about
what is that about that was just about
someone falling apart emotionally and
mentally and really confession to make I
did not write that tune I sang it that
was Randy Backman is that right yeah I
made a few changes here and there but he
named it never gave me any writing
credits I say okay did you do share the
land yet you need a phrase you do little
that
[Music]
have you been around
have you Dania share a common down on
different things that people do
have you been aware you've got brothers
and sisters who care about what's gonna
happen to you in here from now
maybe I'll be there to shake your head
I'll be there to share the land they'll
be giving away when we don't live
together but talking about together now
maybe I'll be there to shake your hand
baby I'll be there we share the land
they'll be giving away
I'm talking about together now you know
that one was banned in Texas and some of
the southern is ha mystic personally I
was against that's wrong because I felt
that Mister monistic but no I that's
that's agree I really believe yeah
Burton thanks for coming in with you
what song did I not did I not get to
this the biggest one we didn't do is no
sugar do you know it was a flipside of
American woman's number one and Bill
give us a little that pleasure
if you
[Music]
only feeling
deep inside
find the corner
rocking hi
siren suits
[Applause]
[Music]
sudden darkness
but I can see
no sugar tonight I'm a coffee no sugar
tonight and my tea no sugar to stand
beside me no sugar with me
[Music]